oh hit that freeze oh oh you gotta
freeze weight is that part of yourself
those are the power moves dog you don't
know
so today uh Joe and I will be playing
Twisted Metal black from 2001 on a PS4 I
insisted on it I like the better
graphics I was like I want to look worse
what do you think about that yeah well
yeah explains a lot on the show all
right here we go
we've come to the Q a where I asked the
cues or I kick your a you played all the
twists I did I did I played one through
black and wow it was one of the big
co-op games sure that I think brought
together a lot of people with my friends
at least so it has a fun place in my
heart this is gonna be fun
who are you I have chosen sweet too we
gotta talk about the car because like
every car has been an ice cream truck in
some form nice chain gun yeah like I
think the chain guns are pretty iconic
to the car too oh 100
time to play yes we are going
head-to-head or okay I'm on bottom there
was a moment where uh
we're in the sand dunes to shoot some
Vegas stuff
and the ice cream truck literally almost
flips yep you know putting myself In
Harm's Way is nothing new and uh I did a
lot of my old snots I know there's one
terrifying thing that I think it was one
of the last things that we shot oh my
God yeah yeah I was up on the hood of
the car and I was pounding on the glass
and then proceeded to smash it was
insane and then remembered with Tara
that Thomas Hayden Church was still in
the car and I remember I jumped off and
opened up the door and there's Thomas
kind of Frozen like shaking his head and
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry oh it's all right
it's all right we're good kid
I was sick of that clown sweet tooth has
always wanted to have fans and he's
always wanted to that's why he's kind of
wishing for and
that's kind of what takes him on his
journey really
say some childhood trauma that led him
to where he was yeah exactly exactly but
I'm really excited for fans to say oh
yeah yeah I'm really excited too
[Laughter]
did you get me
getting a chance to come in and do
Twisted Metal which is an iconic
franchise for me as a gamer it's like
it's weight you got to carry your
shoulders because you know you
understand how Gamers think you
understand what Gamers want so we wanted
to recapture the fun of couch Co-op of
sitting there with your buddies and
they're talking trash and you know
seeing the hits and do our best to kind
of replicate that on on the television
screen absolutely
you know what I remember seeing your
audition because when we watched years
it was like oh they're a sweet tooth
there was absolutely no question I don't
really know how to feel about that but
yeah
wow perfect 10 too I got it is that a
trophy yeah you got a trophy well done
thank you you are too kind Joe's
wrestling and knowing what he can do
physically was just like exactly what we
were looking for we have Will Arnett
voicing Sweet Tooth which is amazing
under there
[__] had a lot of fun with that for me
it was a blast to portray a character
like this who's just so off the rails
but there definitely wasn't any
restrictions what you're putting out
here for a while because you know that
he's going to match it and it's going to
be awesome surprise
[Laughter]
he's waiting for the questions he's
waiting for the questions
yeah yeah yeah why don't you take this
one Joe
what was it like working with Stephanie
Anthony oh awesome uh you know you
couldn't ask for two better people uh
you know especially for a uh a newer uh
actor as myself to work with I mean uh a
lot of fun
some of the fight scenes that we had in
the casino uh were were definitely a lot
of fun especially with Anthony in his
propensity to throw himself on objects
and make people think that I'm shut up
oh hi there
oh that tickled I think all the stuff we
shot that was supposed to be the Vegas
desert was really fun I mean it was
really hot it was you know oh no
oh God take the question kid take those
questions damn it
[Music]
good game
you got me you got me though yeah that
was a pretty good move just had to try
against that building